what inspired you to re-imagine um the
original movie as a series with
gender-swapped leading worlds
well i grew up in the industry i started
acting when i was 10. um so this world
has always been one that you know i have
a deep connection to uh
it's where i grew up um i definitely
have my 10 000 hours in this space
and the original movie you know when it
came out in 1994
i just remember it sort of sent this
shock wave through the industry
everybody was kind of like
holy [ __ ] is this really what it's like
and um
so
uh yeah when i sort of thought about
re-envisioning and sort of using that as
a jumping off point i thought well if i
can do it from a female perspective
i think i might have something to say
i might have something
sort of
in this world that i can bring forth
that feels like it's um
of value in 2022 and so that was really
kind of the entry point um
and really just trying to sort of
explore
these two women and this kind of really
unconventional female sort of love story
in a way uh so that was that was what
drew me to it
and diane are brilliant in this and what
made them the perfect fit for their
roles
well i mean obviously i'm an actor and
so
you know both of these roles to me like
i really wanted that sort of dichotomy
between
what they present as versus what they
are in in real life and so you know with
diane i really needed somebody who
appeared as one thing who was just this
totally polished
almost mechanical
precision machine but then behind closed
doors
i needed her to be super vulnerable and
really raw and diane just has that
inherently like she's so strong and
powerful
but she's also so deeply kind of
vulnerable um
and with lou with kiernan shipka's
character it was kind of the same you
know i wanted somebody who kind of
appeared as one thing but then had this
stuff running behind the surface that
was just like oh wait a second i think i
know who this is but maybe i don't know
who this is
so they both really embodied that
and
are there any parts of the show that are
inspired by your own experiences any
particular themes that really happened
uh
well
yes i definitely would be lying if i
said that there weren't a lot of
personal things in this i mean i
like lou moved to los angeles from you
know i grew up in hamilton ontario and i
moved to la when i was
um
19 and didn't know anybody and grew up
with a mom who loved movies and
hollywood and
sort of you know had a very similar kind
of trajectory in terms of that entry
point and um
yeah it's it's definitely you know it's
definitely an industry that everybody
wants to be in and everybody wants that
proximity to greatness and
it's very intoxicating
and it i think always will be and so
yeah definitely
uh the show
definitely is a is a is a reflection of
my experiences
sorry as well as being the showrunner
you also start in the series um what was
it like wearing so many hats
uh it was intense for sure um but you
know i feel like i was like ready for it
i've been doing this for so long it just
felt like a natural
progression for me and uh yeah i loved
it i definitely like i like being the
boss